all right we haven't done one of these
panels in a while but it happened I got
these two together Lalo - gosh dad said
the Internet's gonna crack this could be
it
this could be the ending of the internet
getting you two together people are
gonna be very excited
[ __ ] the unholy trinity is finally
together the unholy trinity is finally
together so I guess the most natural way
to start this thing is that we have
found ourselves in the last eight months
or so really in a huge battle of ideas
which is everything that I've made this
show to be and both of you guys have
played a huge role in my evolution and
my ability and desire to be part of this
thing and I like to think I've maybe
played a little role in yours as well
did you ever think that you were gonna
be part of something like this I'll
throw that to you first because because
you come from the farthest away I do
yeah furthest away both both in distance
and probably as far as any kind of
following because I wanted to be part of
the conversation at least on Twitter and
I thought you know there's there's the
people who have some following
themselves people who have a larger
voice and then there are the people who
just follow them and comment between
each other I at least wanted to be part
of that conversation just because I felt
there was such something really wrong in
the conversation was just throwing out
labels like it's nothing yeah but I
guess yeah it's it's good that um that I
had enough voice to be sitting here with
you guys now yeah so there he is sitting
in Chile going I see something wrong on
the left and I want to be part of it now
you a professor in Canada again I did
not know who you were a year ago I
hadn't read your books yet sorry yeah I
hope you rectified this they've all been
rectified and now you've given me an
autographed copy so they'll be double
read but but completely different waffle
life right a Christian Palestinian
atheist a Jewish power Jewish atheist
remedies Lebanese now in Canada walk
into a bar you became part of this thing
- when was your moment that you really
thought you had to be part of this so it
it started when I I would see
the what I call the ostrich brigade
mentality where you you would see the
incredible increase in the Islamization
in my case in Montreal and where you try
to engage people to discuss some of
these issues and people were simply
unwilling to tackle what was as clear as
the existence of gravity
yeah and that's probably the impetus of
what got me into this yes were you
seeing it literally in real life before
you were seeing it online what we oh
yeah yeah so so for example I'll just
give you one of many possible examples
until about 2003 so I spent two years
here at UC Irvine and then we went back
to Montreal I had probably seen a single
woman in my entire life in Montreal
since the mid-70s wearing any Islamic
garb it just never happened from 2003 to
today there are many areas in Montreal
where you could walk around where 20 30
40 percent of the women are dressed in
this garb not now you might say well who
cares so what but that's that's that's
symptomatic of other issues that are
also happening right and so trying to
engage people to discuss these types of
issues as I have on my show for example
was a very difficult thing to do because
everybody had their head deeply buried
in the sand yeah I mean speaking of
buried in the sand I mean I was part of
the progressive world for a long time I
mean I was deeply in it deeper than you
guys probably atone for your sins I I
don't think there's enough atoning that
can ever be done I'm trying it every day
but I think I was really happy to be
just be a liberal be a progressive like
you know somewhat twenty years ago we
seem like very strong on the left and we
knew very clearly that a lot of problems
in society too right from religion
mmm-hmm and it seems like the left was
very happy to call out the Christian
left and and say you know well there's
problems in the Bible you know evolution
is not being taught to to children
homophobia the the fight against gay
marriage is principally from many you
know Mormon churches or whatever sure
but it what triggered me is now as if
records is now that we are having the
same fight about Islam and majority
Muslim states and groups that it was our
group are
side the liberal the progressive that
said no what you're saying now is
considered racism or well no we can't
have that yeah and that's what at least
pushed me over the edge to really are
okay no I I feel like I have to do this
because I can't let my group this good
group you know just you know go off the
edge you know and the worst part is that
now the word racist and bigoted is used
in such a damaging way like nothing and
I think that is really liberal
kryptonite it's like we're so strong you
know it's like the saran kind of
character you have so much going for us
but our weakness is being called racist
that's the last thing any of us want to
be called and they know it and they use
it they use it but you know just last
week I mean one of my former colleagues
publicly called me a bigot on Twitter
and it's like I actually my reaction I
swear to you my reaction was I thought
it was funny I was like this is all you
got yeah another one I throw more
colleagues called me a bigot recently on
Twitter but but that so does that show
right there that we we are winning this
thing and and I'm hesitant to say it
because because there's still a lot of
work that has to be done for sure but
there has been an awakening we see it
just in the social media where it feels
like we live in a social media world
more than reality isn't this weird I
mean this is the first time we're
sitting down together and and you know
frankly I mean not just you know having
gotten chance to meet you and I should
thank you for offering voices like ours
and opportunity to to flourish important
medium but the number of lovely people
that I've met online I mean yes of
course there are some bad guys but just
a number of people that I will probably
never have the pleasure of meeting in
person but who've written to me really
personal stuff that I actually take the
time to read and respond and so to
answer your earlier question what got me
into this more generally I'm a guy about
ideas I'm a guy about connecting and now
you're giving me all these tools to
connect to thousands hundreds of
thousands millions of people I'm a kid
in a candy store
and so it becomes very difficult to
extricate myself from this world because
it it feeds my desire to connect with
people and discuss ideas yeah you know
that's interesting because I've seen a
big change in the tone of what's going
on on Twitter particularly and you know
everyone's talking about how they're
struggling financially right now in the
business
not making sense and it sounds like
they're starting you know they took away
my lady innopolis is a check which you
know it sounds silly right like in and
of itself it doesn't sound like anything
that great I have mine and I pray that
they never take it away from me but they
were doing they're taking a punitive
action on someone just because they
don't like what he says right so if they
didn't really like what he says then
they could have suspended him for a day
if he had violated the terms of service
but instead they did something very
petty and then it caused his influence
to only grow more and I feel like that's
very indicative of what this
authoritarian left and this regressive
thing is all about they keep trying to
trick you into thinking they're doing
something good and at the same time
they're really doing something pretty
terrible but have you heard of who's
heading the truth and Safety Council of
Twitter well I know there's like 30
people is the ones are easy and right oh
yeah oh really yeah Anita sarkeesian is
one of the one and I I went after her I
I did a sad truth clip where I
demonstrated how outlandish her content
analysis of video games are in terms of
the the means by which she analyzes the
content to then arrive at the conclusion
that it's all patriarchal oppression I
mean wouldn't pass the the most minimal
test of scientific rigor mm-hmm and yet
she's the one who's now going to decide
whether what you say or not there's
appropriate horrible yeah I think the
most important thing to me out of
anything we talk about out of atheism or
science is freedom of speech and I think
you've made that so clear on this show
that you're willing to talk with anyone
and let all voices be heard and to me
that's everything because I can't even
like God said it said I'm about ideas
and also these not just giving ideas but
the absorption of ideas I want to hear
even the craziest ideas out there and
see where what I think about it but when
people are censored well they're selling
means like this idea is so bad Lalo you
can't hear this I've decided this for
you yeah aren't you happy aren't you so
glad your I filtered ideas for you know
and to me even if you know as far as my
opposition to many Muslim ideas but on
when I back in what year was this when
there was the Ground Zero mosque right
close to to to where the towers fell I
actually had an argument with a lot of
people I knew who thought it was in a
to New York and Sibiu and I I fought
against a lot of people and they were
surprised by my position I was like no
people have a right to their faith and
to practice if they want as not as far
as that I'm for it or I agree with it
but you know people have freedom of
speech they have freedom of practice now
in universities in universities God said
is is that people are saying like no
well you know if it offends somebody for
person has hurt a person of a background
like me and God it was like those are
the people's feelings they want to
protect essentially God's feelings my
feelings and say oh Lalo you're so
delicate you know I'm aren't you happy
I'm a white person yeah and I am worried
about your your feelings as a brown man
you'll be clear because you guys are a
little brown or a little browner than me
and I'm fatter than both of you so yeah
I'm a little Balder than both of you I'm
really losing this thing then yeah well
that's why the the debate and and what's
going on on Twitter especially I found
lately that I feel like my interactions
on there
don't hold as much value as they did
like I think now six months ago it was
actually a really special time when I
was connecting with all of these people
and I've and even today I still connect
with all these people that have come on
my show or from all over the world but I
do find there's something strange is
happening and we've talked about this a
little bit that within this community of
fighters and free thinkers and
secularists that it's one thing if
you're one of these people and you live
you know in the Middle East and you're
truly oppressed but we're finding more
and more that a huge percentage of
people that are free thinkers and
secular people an atheist are anonymous
and they're living in the West this is a
huge problem and it actually takes value
away from the conversations with me I'm
tired of talking to people that are
anonymous if you live in the comforts of
the West it's not like the three of us
are the bravest [ __ ] on the
planet these people and I I want people
to step up didn't you have is it Luna so
I had Lube none actually I'm glad you
brought it up because so the long story
short of it is we've had to take the
interview down for now and we are safety
concerns for safety concerns which I had
done I assure you both and the audience
that I did my due diligence in terms of
discussing with the right people should
we even do this
or any of that we're I can't say much
more right now but you haven't heard the
last of its but I think think of money
we're talking about bravery yeah right
and and about you know the influence
that is afforded to us by engaging in
this medium Lubner wrote to me privately
very earlier to you know to solicit my
advice as to what to do and so on and I
took that with quite a bit of humility
and here's this woman who's I mean I
know what she's going through and yet
very very quickly she's on your show I
mean that's that's the whole thing like
that the the possibility to bring to
light what these people are experiencing
in these horrible environments well
that's the irony is that the same week
that I'm being attacked by a former
colleague who I never had one
disagreement over with ever the same
week that this person's calling me a
bigot I'm actually talking to someone
that is trying to stand up for all the
right liberal values and I'm still I
can't get it my into it much further but
I'm still dealing with some of that
stuff and trying to help her and it's
like that's the disconnect I have
nothing against anyone that is Muslim
more than I would have anything against
anyone that's Christian or Jewish or
janus or whatever but we have to help
people to be able to express the same
liberal values that we want everyone
else to express and we're we the three
of us for some reason aren't afraid of
that well and our friends on the Left
seem to be professional to build on what
you just said I've received comments
from people who said the fact that I
share my personal history to the extent
that it makes some Muslims look bad then
I'm a bad person so I don't have right
of ownership of my own history right
keep quiet about what happened to your
Lebanon because don't you know that by
speaking about it you're you are
stigmatizing these people so my being
executed potentially is stigmatizing the
other so it's become a truly a perverse
form of thinking yeah for the people
that want to know more about that just
watch the interview that I just the one
on one that I just did with you wait I
heard a regressive well-known regressive
Glenn Greenwald talking about this once
they
he thinks the best people to talk about
these subjects are people in
muslim-majority States and it doesn't
make sense for a straight white male in
the US or in Europe to be speaking about
this one of the reasons I got into this
was reading the writings of right Badawi
you know in Saudi Arabia a guy who if
you you know there's some translations
of his blog online and it's just
wonderful stuff about secularism you
know progressing his own society and he
gets arrested for simply blogging
talking about secularism and gets
flogged for it gets whipped and if he
did I have that freedom he doesn't so
when we talk about these subjects we can
do it with the freedom that those people
in those societies don't have and one
there's many ways to do it wants to talk
about it ourselves one is to you know
address certain opponents of that the
other is to give them a voice like like
you've been doing but even that is
incredibly complicated that you had a
whole you know drama with Lubner you
know putting up her video then changing
it to just sound then taking it all down
because of her safety because of saying
something online in the societies we
come from Canada the US and Chile that's
unthinkable right it would never happen
and that's why when when Glenn says
something like you just said what he
says well we have to let them deal with
it you're throwing them to the wool
right not only you're throwing them to
the Wolves you're throwing your own
ideals to the walls I don't care what
color religion or anything anyone is but
I will stand up for the basic principles
that Matt talk about here all the time
imagine if he had said that you know 30
years ago about the gay community in the
US why should I is a straight white
person talk about the struggles of gay
individuals yeah why not let them talk
about in their own community you know it
means a lot yeah that people outside of
that community talk about it it does if
they have a freedom to talk about it it
reflects a tolerance there's a lot of
good reasons why it should come from
outside the community yeah certainly
from on the other side I've received
criticism for engaging moderate Muslim
voices so as you yeah yeah I've had a
lot of these folks on my show and
including I haven't had yet Tariq Fattah
but he'd be amongst that group and
people who are very much against
engagement with Muslims are like why are
you doing this right so you you really
see what happens when people are very
Doug
maduk in their positions they lose the
capacity to reason whether it be on one
side or the other right so it's really
that swai you know my lonely innopolis
for mention this to me and I've really
taken this idea and run with it but that
it's really about totalitarians it's
really about authoritarians versus free
thinkers right because what you're
saying is if you have or if I had Maajid
Nawaz on well now some people that are
actually racist or bigoted or whatever
okay so yeah you shouldn't have this
Muslim all right right okay now that's
real bigotry and then people on the Left
will say ah you found your porch monkey
and we know that that that's not my
phrase that's actually someone well no
what's his name on the left you can can
I point out where the little story
behind that Glenn Greenwald wrote a
couple years ago an article about sam
harris something with the title
Islamophobia talking about Islamophobia
he mentions right in the first paragraph
Hussein and Nathan Lee and both these
guys have said racial slurs against
Maajid Nawaz yeah now Glenn Greenwald
did he call out those guys for something
I guess no it's so it's very selected
now has Sam Harris ever said in a racial
slur against any Muslim knepper not that
we don't we yeah so so what do we do
with all this you know that's all I
think I've ended most of my discussions
about all this like what what do we do
because as I asked you previously
there's a certain amount of energy that
this that goes into this you know Sam
described it as an opportunity cost when
when he went on real-time to discuss his
book waking up which was a guide to
spirituality without religion it his
whole that whole tour about inner peace
was hijacked by your gross by the
tornado of Ben Affleck yeah so the worst
worst possible thing that could have
happened happened you know so what do
you guys do in terms of energy and all
that like it's a lot to put into this
right thank you
it is especially I mean I mean I'm sure
we're all very busy but I mean I I have
a oftentimes an 18-hour day career as a
professor but you know what it's it's
too important you know I talked about
the tragedy in the comments and maybe I
could take two seconds is your tragedy
calm is an economic phenomenon where
let's suppose you've got a plot of land
and you've got ten farmers all of whom
are using their livestock to graze the
land and if they keep grazing the land
the land won't be able to survive and so
they come to a gentlemen agreement where
they say for the next two years nobody's
going to graze the land now the tragedy
of the Commons happens where each of the
farmer says well what if I cheat and I
allow my livestock to graze this land
hopefully the other nine will be
honorable and everybody wins I get to
graze the land and the others will be
kind the problem is that everybody
thinks that and then they they screw it
up well to draw the analogy here what
happens is that everybody thinks that
somebody else should get involved in
this debate right I mean I'm busy today
with my kids I'm busy buying tomatoes
and the groceries let Dave Rubin worry
about this let lala worry about this you
know I'm too busy with my life
no everybody has to be engaged and
that's how you resolve it from having
the big platform that you have two
people talking about it in parties not
everybody has Dave Reubens platform but
ironically I only got the platform
because I was talking well I think
that's that's the truth and you look
it's trench war it's trench war of ideas
right it happens everywhere it happens
at the bar it happens at the party it
happens in the classroom just be engaged
that's how you win the battle if you
always think that somebody else will
fight that fight for you we will lose
yeah so when it comes to these people
that are anonymous I so you were
originally anonymous right or you're
your - no no I your Twitter lander had
your name yeah but you were known as
Chile's atheist and it was this name was
Chile's atheist but my handle at was
always allowed - gosh right I actually
had to sit down with my family and talk
about whether I was gonna use my name
because I was gonna talk about Islam and
that's not really the subject that
especially having my last name - gosh is
not a typical last name even for Chile
or anywhere yeah so I mean that has -
that comes with it with a cost but I you
know a lot of people are anonymous
online but it does come down to the
support they give us and they have to do
their part - yeah but it like God said
we they don't all have time for this
they don't all have time to go into the
depths so for example Reza Aslan who you
were talking about before has that CNN
interview where he's he's you know about
FGM and discarding and everything well
not every everybody kind of knows he's
dishonest they've seen a lot of bits and
but we can take the time to discredit a
lot of things we can say when he says
FGM or female general mutilation is just
an African problem we can say no there
is actually evidence that it exists in
Iraq and even as far as Indonesia yeah
you know huge story just cry about it or
if he or he says that in Indonesia women
are 100% equal to two men when there's
you know child marriage
there's FGM there are morality police
throughout cities he makes a bunch of
other claims that in in in terms of the
female genital mutilation that since it
exists in other Christian states in
Africa
therefore therefore is not associated to
Islam now if you thought about Judaism
circumcision is not only done by Jews it
is also done by Christians does this
mean it has no connection to do Judaism
of course not right but see people need
to have that understanding I put that on
Twitter I put that in a video people
knew okay this sounds like something's
wrong with this but we can say that we
have certain resources and time to say
this God has you know resources and the
background academically to say that and
a lot of these people need that yeah you
know they don't have all they have their
lives or have their work there's a cost
of you know going online publicly with
their name where they work you know who
knows who their boss is but you know
they can still give support as far as
they can
yeah could I just just to answer this I
mean there's a real professional cost
never mind personal safety cost hmm to
my taking the positions that I do right
because the typical phenomenally tepid
cowardly University might look at my
stuff and while they should be
encouraged by the things I say might say
well this this guy's too too vociferous
right yeah and so I take a lot of
professional risks in speaking out
openly right I mean maybe University X
that might have otherwise made me an
offer might decide not to precisely
because I speak but frankly again my
individual selfish career goals are
grossly superseded by the greater battle
of ideas and hence I am compelled I have
to speak yeah what's interesting about
that is you know in a just world or if
the world wasn't as upside I would be
rewarded for it well not only would you
be rewarded but there would be men
more people like you right there would
be many more professor tenures tenured
professors who would be relentlessly
saying whatever they wanted and even if
it had nothing to do with this specific
topic or free speech but there would be
tons of professors doing this and yet
here we are can I tell you an incredibly
banal story of how cowardly people are
there was a colleague of mine who at one
point we were chatting about something
and she said well I don't really want to
take this position openly because but I
said well why are you afraid you're
tenured her his or her response let me
put it this way this was about going to
a party it was yeah but you know what if
I take this position maybe the
departmental chair will give me courses
on a Tuesday to teach and that might
coincide with my taking my kid to soccer
practice in other words his or her
capacity to want to be engaged in a
particularly important discussion was
reduced to whether she gets a teaching
assignment on Tuesday or not when you
have this kind of sort of myopic view of
big issues that's that's not good